je veux répondre à la sécurité qui
attend est une solution je disais
immigration c'est la mère de toutes les
batailles c'est pour ça que nous avons
une délinquance aussi explosif c'est à
cause de l'immigration donc si on
arrêtait l'immigration zéro y aura plus
de délinquance travail en aura il y aura
quasiment plus louis à ça j'en suis sûr
deuxièmement deuxièmement les cercles
avec des immigrés qui sont délinquants
dont louis en tout cas des immigrés ou
des enfants d'immigrés c'est bien
français ils seront alors justement on
va traiter ça laissez moi finir deuxième
question deuxième question donc je
supprime le regroupement familial le
droit d'asile ne sera plus qu'une
poignée de gens qui seront et pas 130000
comme aujourd'hui les étudiants au
pareil les va toutes les sources d'eau
des migrations jeu les cas d'accord je
supprime la et me je supprime les
menaces relations sociales non
contributives aux étrangers je supprime
le droit du sol c'est à dire qu'on ne
sera plus
français parce qu'on est né en france de
parents étrangers nés de parents
français voilà ça c'est les grandes
mesures pour arrêter l'immigration
j'expulse les chômeurs étrangers de plus
de six mois et nous arrivons à la
sécurité pourquoi il y avait autant de
délinquance aussi sa cause du laxisme
judiciaire
[Musique]